[Music]
so last week sit down with Brigitte
Gabriel received quite possibly the most
positive reaction that we've ever had to
an interview
I'd say that well over 90 percent of the
responses that I saw on YouTube Twitter
and Facebook were appreciative of our
discussion of her incredible story
growing up in Lebanon during the Civil
War about the roots of radical Islam and
what living in a free society is really
all about people were in awe of
Brigitte's personal story amazed by her
passion impressed by her candor or some
combination thereof if you haven't seen
her episode yet but you only have a few
minutes check out the last five minutes
of our chat to see what a true love of
Liberty and freedom is all about we'll
put the link to that right here in the
description below oh and for the record
I wasn't tearing up because of her
impassioned speech it was because of
these damn bright lights they were
getting to my retinas you know how it
can be I mention the reaction to our
interview with Brigitte because it
reiterates a lesson that I've
consistently learned while doing this
show before we had Brigitte on I talked
to my team about whether we should have
her on at all after all Brigitte is
hated by a lot of people who call her
the usual buzzwords like racist bigot
far-right extremists and so on while we
all know that the people who are using
these words are becoming the new boy who
cried wolf and that these words
themselves are losing their meaning by
the minute the chill effect these words
have still remains in certain quarters
even in my case when I'm selecting my
guests I do have to think for a moment
if there is going to be some sort of
cost for me to sit down with someone I
still get a ton of hate for talking to
my lowly innopolis my externa [ __ ]
Tommy Robinson Paul Joseph Watson and a
couple other people in none of those
cases none of those cases do I regret
having the conversations regardless of
the blowback these interviews may have
caused me but it does bring to light an
important topic it's not just those who
are being targeted as bigots and racists
who are in the firing line of those who
would like to silence us it's also the
people willing to talk to those people
and hear them out this guilt by
association is incredibly dangerous
because it can bite any of us for having
a family member or even a friendship
with someone who shares political views
that fall out of the mainstream
should we disown people with use
different than ours
should we defame them should we publicly
humiliate them all of these are small
steps towards reporting them to the
authorities the wrong thing we should
also note that in the online world
there's an information battle constantly
happening when you put Bridget's name in
Google the first site that comes up
which isn't one that directly affiliated
to her is Islamophobia dot org which is
part of care the Council on
american-islamic relations now think
back to my interview with Brigitte for
just a second what was the bigoted part
after living through everything she has
does she strike you as the problem in
society does she strike you as a bigot
or racist or a right-wing nut I don't
think so what I think is most
interesting about the assault on
conversation is how recent this
phenomenon is my friend and mentor Larry
King has built his legendary career on
talking to people from every walk of
life and from every part of the world on
five days of any giving week he could
talk to a member of the Ku Klux Klan
then Louis Farrakhan than the cast of
friends then Magic Johnson and then the
Pope nobody ever accused Larry of
sharing all their beliefs just because
he talked to all of them actually this
very concept would have been seen as
totally ludicrous I'm proud to say that
I know Larry pretty well and it's his
curious mind and real sense of wonder
that made and still make him want to
talk to all sorts of people doing all
sorts of different things as you know
it's my policy that sunlight is the best
disinfectant that people with bad ideas
will eventually hang themselves if given
the room to do so and I consistently try
to do that this growing sense of guilt
by association is just the next level of
what the regressive left has built it's
not enough just to label someone a bigot
anymore now we have to tar and feather
them so that other people will be afraid
to talk to them as well and if you're
willing to talk to someone outside of
their accepted group Vultar and feather
you to in an effort to shut down any
furthering of conversation and yes
unfortunately
I do see this phenomenon far more on the
Left than on the right these days it's
almost as if when you cut through the
hysteria and the screaming and the
slandering that they don't even believe
their own ideas in the first place so
they don't want counter ideas heard but
they also want to make sure people
aren't entertaining other ideas in the
first place this is incredibly dangerous
and it's not a game that I'll be taking
part in we can't give them an inch
because they will keep taking and taking
until there's nothing of us left between
this silencing of those who veer from
the mainstream and the YouTube be
monetization that I discussed last week
those of us who really are fighting for
free speech have our work cut out for us
and I am up for the challenge by the way
fortunately we're continuing our
partnership with learn Liberty this week
and joining me is assistant professor of
economics at the University of Tampa
abby hall abby is also an affiliated
scholar at the Mercatus institute and a
research fellow with the independent
institute a nonpartisan educational
think-tank we're going to talk economics
war and peace the drug war our
militarized police and much more I'll
gladly accept my guilt by association to
her and we'll see how it goes as to
whether she can say the same about me
[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
the good people over at learn Liberty
today and joining me is an assistant
professor of economics at the University
of Tampa and an affiliated scholar with
both the Mercatus Center and the
foundation for economic education dr.
abby hall welcome to the rubin report
thank you for having me
how was my intro there I felt good about
that good work I liked it
all right there's a lot I want to get
into it you because I was looking at
your bio and a lot of the stuff that you
talked about that you specialize in is
stuff but I really like that we haven't
done a ton on so can we jump into
foreign policy first sure foreign policy
to me seems like one of the craziest
things that we have going on these days
because everyone's talking about it and
yet it seems like no one knows what
they're talking about is that a
generally fair statement I'll start us
off on here that just everyone's always
talking about all this stuff and nobody
really knows what's going on not nobody
but the masses if it's comforting at all
having a lot of foreign policy issues
that people know nothing about it is not
anything that is new to today however I
would say that foreign policy is an area
where a lot of people are I think
rationally fairly ignorant just because
a lot of foreign policy people think I
think often incorrectly that foreign
policy doesn't have any kind of impact
on what's going on domestically yeah so
I like that you set it up that way that
it's not necessarily any worse now I
think it seems like it's somehow worse
now because of social media so you just
see people all day long who you know
don't really know what they're saying
and they're constantly saying things but
as someone that knows a bit about
foreign policy what are what are some of
the tenants you need in a solid sound
foreign policy a complicated question
why you're here it is um I don't I don't
pretend to be able to sit from my
position and prescribe foreign policy
that is not what I see my role as an
economist
as as being but I can say that economics
gives us a lot of insights as to how we
should expect foreign policy to work or
in a lot of cases to not work in the way
that it's intended whether we're talking
about humanitarian interventions or if
we're talking about military
intervention economics and the
frameworks that are given to us or that
we can talk about from an economic
perspective are helpful in understanding
what's going on with a lot of foreign
policy yeah how much of our foreign
policy is directly economically based
like we like to think oh we do this for
humanitarian reasons or we do this
because of some other reason but is it
at the end of the day is it like 90
percent that's really just about
economics it's hard to describe
something as being just economic as I
try to pitch my students when they're in
class everything is economic problem if
you look at it hard enough because the
economics propel course but if you look
at a foreign intervention there is
absolutely what we would call the public
choice aspect of foreign policy what
Dwight Eisenhower referred to as a
military-industrial complex so you have
congressional leaders you have the
Pentagon you have private interest who
all have a vested interest in engaging
and foreign policy or particular types
of foreign policy I should say
regardless of whether or not is actually
productive we're serving the quote
unquote common good yeah when you say
particular types you talk about some
sort of military intervention military
intervention although one thing that we
have observed for the last several
decades humanitarian interventions are
becoming more and more something that's
falling under the umbrella of military
execution regardless of whether or not
that's appropriate yeah so when you see
something like Syria going on right now
there's a humanitarian disaster are they
bringing in economists to say guys we
there's a humanitarian disaster there's
there's people you know hundreds of
thousands of something like five hundred
thousand people have died over the last
eight years or something like that like
what are the
economic choices we have to make to make
this viable or is it just that the
machine just kind of exists and and
they're just going to make the decisions
and do what they want I can't say when I
know exactly what the Obama
administration went now the Trump
administration are doing as far as
consulting economists about what to do
in Syria unfortunately and this has been
a point of a lot of the research that
I've done is people tend to think about
foreign intervention as being something
really simple it's a math problem or
very just linear here's a problem we
want to get from this point to that
point and here's a solution that's
supposed to fix it so we go from A to B
to C right unfortunately that is not how
things work yeah I ever worked that way
no it has never been made amusing not
that I'm aware of um things are not
linear like that and so when you think
about issues especially something that's
a complex foreign policy where you are
dealing with millions of actors and
parts of you know an economy social
issues political issues all of those
things are coming together and they're
working or not working but when you
intervene in one place in that system
it's totally just fantastic thinking to
look at that and go sure if we intervene
at one part in the system there's no way
that there's going to be an impact in
other parts of that system as well and
that's where you wind up running into
some really on nefarious unintended
consequences which we have seen over and
over and over right it is also sort of
the idea of like mission creep where
they you know they always sort of have
one goal and then it keeps becoming
another goal and another goal and
another goal and then you don't even
know where you started at the beginning
maybe part of that when we talk about
mission creep that's certainly part of
the economics of bureaucracy and one
thing about foreign intervention of
really any flavor whether we're talking
about humanitarian aid or we're talking
about war it's all done in this
bureaucratic regime so overlapping
layers of bureaucracy bureaucratic firms
don't compete for profit like a standard
firm one so anyway I typically explain
it
you have a for-profit firm they look at
their financial statements at the end of
the quarter they're earning a profit
that's indicating to them that they are
providing something that is adding value
to society a negative profit or a loss
indicates the opposite bureaucracies
however they're not competing for profit
or loss they are competing for
government resources the pieces of some
larger budget how do they convey that
they should get a bigger piece of that
budget that they should have more
personnel by taking on more and more
activities which are important to the
powers that be yeah so just to be clear
they basically they're competing for
this budget so they have to spend money
even in cases where they wouldn't have a
good reason to is that fair to say
absolutely there's no incentive to cost
minimize right if you are deceptive
right I mean there's reasons not to do
it I convened your budget will be cut
right you if I'm if I'm a government
agency and I go to you as the federal
government and I say hey I can do the
exact same job that I'm doing with 20
percent less money the next year I'm
going to have 20 percent less my budget
which is not what you're incentivized to
do as somebody operating a bureaucracy
now this doesn't mean that the people
who are working in the government are
necessarily if you know terrible people
who are sitting there wringing their
hands trying to get as much money as
possible but as an economist we look at
that and we say well this is the
incentive structure that they face so
how did that system get built I mean how
did this come to be it's now I'm not an
economist but it sounds quite ridiculous
I would want something that was slim and
trim and took as little from the people
as possible and that could you know
every year become more efficient and
need less resources and all that and
that's quite literally the reverse of
what we have one thing about this
bureaucratic system is that there is
that incentive to expand not saying that
it's not possible to constrain it but
there's actually an entire branch of
economics called constitutional
political economy which is trying to
answer the question of if we want
something like a government who will
provide quote-unquote national defense
or roads or education whatever you want
to put in that bucket how do we
construct a political system where we
can
empower our leaders to do the things
that we want them to do and yet
simultaneously constrain them to not go
outside of those stated confines that we
would prefer where those functions that
we want them to fulfill in terms of how
we got there it's a tricky question
requires a lot of historical knowledge
my experience is looking at how things
have evolved militarily particularly
that military industrial complex because
we've always seen a relationship between
private actors and public actors that's
nothing that's new however this massive
kind of military spending that we have
right now is not something that is
always been observed in the US yeah and
that really starts I think if you want
to pinpoint it during the interwar years
between World War one and World War two
because you've got contracting rules
that change so it used to be if I had an
idea for something that the military
could use I would pitch that idea to
various boards they would look at it
they would look to see it was a good
idea they send out bids but now and this
kind of started during that period the
rules of the game have changed for those
kinds of contracts so instead of who can
build something the cheapest it might be
oh these we have a relationship with
this particular company or they're
familiar with our processes and so it's
built up over time do you think there's
any kind of functional way to roll back
some of that I mean if you wanted to get
the system do you want to have a fair
bidding process or something that was
going to be a little more fiscally
responsible any of that is it possible
to roll back things that are inside of
such a massive complex as you're
mentioning I would like to say that I
think anything is possible
uh-huh I'm not sure that I think it's
particularly likely yeah you have
massive entrenched interest for I mean
you look at something like drones or
tanks there have been a tank for example
that the military has said for years we
do not want them yeah and yet they
continue to be manufactured
and they are quite literally sitting in
a compound somewhere and they are just
rusting yeah why are we still
manufacturing these it's because the
places where they're manufactured their
elected officials keenly aware of the
fact that if they shut down these
factories some of their constituency is
going to be unemployed that does not
bode well for their reelection they
fight really hard to keep those things
in place and so you're fighting those
battles yeah at so many different
junctures I'm honestly not really sure
what it would what it would take
yeah how could you even start to fight
that at the political level because
you'd have to have a politician who
would be willing to say to his own
people you're going to lose some jobs
because it's the unfortunately in this
case it's the right thing to do right
and that we don't get maybe politicians
like that no and there's actually a
famous economist named FA Hayek who in
chapter 10 of his book the Road to
Serfdom talks about why the worst get on
top so why it is that you are unlikely
to have those kinds of political
officials get into place because the
people who are going to seek out those
positions and people who are going to
importantly be successful in those
positions are not of the people who are
going to say let's take one for the team
and roll roll back these policies people
like to think and economists make this
mistake as well that political officials
are publicly interested so they set
aside their own incentives their own
desires and instead they're trying to
fulfill some broader notion of the
public good though they've set it up
oftentimes what's called a social
welfare function so you put societal
welfare on one side of the equal sign
and if you just have all of your math
correct on the other side you can make
people as happy as possible but this
really ignores things that you learn on
quite literally day one of your
economics classes right that people
respond to incentives so political
actors just like any other actor facing
scarcity we should expect that they're
going to respond to incentives
yeah is there any sensible way to
disconnect the politics from the way
that the the military is run and funded
uh-huh yeah I mean it's sort of the same
question that I asked you before but is
there some possible way that we could
have some sort of some sort of
go-between between those two things so
that they could run more efficiently
it's tricky because oftentimes when
people look and even people who
acknowledge that maybe there is an issue
with military spending or the u.s. is
too involved militarily which can get
you in hot water very very quickly
because military is one of the sacred
cows in the United States people will
suggest doing different kinds of things
well maybe you should limit lobbying or
campaign contributions or something like
that but again we go back to one of the
first things that we learn in economics
which is that when you have scarcity so
when people are competing for resources
that competition is ever-present whether
you are competing in the marketplace for
profit if you are in a bureaucracy and
you are competing for pieces of
government budget just because you
change the system not going to change
the fact that there's competition there
but so that entire field looking at how
do we devise
right this is kind of a funny place for
an economist to be because you're
dealing in a system that doesn't deal
with the normal rules of an economy so I
mean it's it isn't it isn't like I can
see because oftentimes when people look
at economists they think that we are
exclusively looking at how markets
operate but economics is much more
fundamentally about human interaction so
given the fact that resources are scarce
and people respond to incentives how is
it that people coordinate in exchange
with each other and in that case then
economics is much more broad in terms of
the scale and the scope of what it is
that economics can talk about so from a
purely economic standpoint if if our
military just had less money do you
think there's any reason that it
couldn't function basically as well as
it functions now
because I would probably like I see no
reason why we couldn't probably cut
let's just pick a small number 10% of
the military budget I suspect there
would be probably no real effect on the
military's ability to do stuff I would
not think that a cut in the military
budget would have a particular effect
although I know as soon as those words
come out of right now I was at 10% I
know I would be I didn't say 40% you
know I think also a lot of it to have to
do with what people see as being
appropriate for the military so again
anytime you see people going to try to
cut military funding there is an
immediate outpouring of this will make
America less safe which I don't think is
true at all if you look at a lot of the
data about
I mean you are incredibly safe in the
United States and in Western Europe for
that matter but certainly at least from
from an army attacking you there's other
there's other risks but those aren't
really military even things like
terrorist attacks which is what people
tend to worry about now
I give actually a fairly a I'm a fairly
regular basis to talk about the
economics of terrorism and one thing
that I do at the very beginning
regardless of who I'm giving the talk to
is I give them a list of two two
PowerPoint slides just full of things
that are much more likely to kill you
than a terrorist attack me a couple of
things let's calm people down being
struck by lightning drowning in a
bathtub
you're more likely to be killed by a
toddler wielding a firearm than you are
to be killed by a terrorist
really babies with guns I mean you know
toddlers can be really scary Manning for
a while I know police officers you're
more likely to be killed by a police
officer in the United States than you
are to be killed by a terrorist and
these statistics also hold for Western
Europe as well so how do we then make
sense of that because that's the media
obviously has us thinking that that's
not the case so how do you make sense of
that you mean just in terms of why do we
why do we tend to stick a she's a
terrorism so I think that there are some
a politically motivated reasons for
really pushing the issue of terrorism
making people think that they are a lot
less safe than they are one thing that
my co-author Chris Coyne and I look at
is how fear is used as a rallying point
fear can make people more accepting of
behaviors of government activities that
maybe they were not comfortable with
before for example if you had told
someone in let's say 1998 that every
time you fly you are going to have your
person in your property subjected to
search by government agents and if you
set off some alarm they can Pat you down
including in areas that you may not be
interested in having people touch you um
people would just say that with
absolutely nuts but then you have
something like 9/11 and then after that
people are convinced that things like
the TSA are important and necessary for
maintaining safety even though we know
statistically and empirically that the
TSA is basically nothing but a giant
money suck yeah so I take it you're not
a big fan of the Patriot Act No yeah
well so what was the goal like what was
the golden if you were the people that
were in charge of writing the Patriot
Act was it then really just let's just
figure out more ways to control the
populace to spy on them like what's the
goal that is there an economic goal for
them or you to make these agencies
bigger because that just gets more money
going in the system I think there is a
goal of expanding the size of your
Bureau that I think that's just the
standard economics of bureaucracy I
think for most people when they attempt
to pass legislation and there are some
exceptions to this I'm sure but I really
don't think that most political actors
are just nefarious and votives I think a
lot of times that people are genuinely
interested in trying to help people
trying to make peep
feel safer note there is a big
difference between feeling safer and
actually being safer but I think one of
the things that we miss out on is the
consequences that come as a result of a
lot of these policies when you give
government additional powers there's the
potential for the abuse of those powers
yeah
and often times it happens in ways that
maybe we can't quite see from the very
beginning it goes back to that linear
thinking that we were talking about a
few minutes ago when you think about
things in that very mathematical fashion
you you miss the fact of like wait a
minute ah maybe maybe we should think
about this a little more carefully yeah
I'm trying to think is there any
instance that you can think of where we
gave the government a certain amount of
power and then eventually it gave that
power back there must be something but I
can't really think of it so there's a
really great book by an economist named
Robert Higgs called crisis and Leviathan
came out in 1987 and his work has been
the basis for a lot of the work that my
co-author Chris and I have done and what
he talked about is what he refers to is
the ratchet effect so you have
government that's growing at some
standard pace then some kind of crisis
happens whether it's something like a
911 or if it's a perceived crisis so if
every American is laying in bed tonight
and thinks that there is a monster under
their bed it can count right it's real
or perceived crisis I'm pretty sure that
half the country thinks that Trump is
under their bed they might but there's
this outcry to do something to mitigate
this threat threat and so government
will expand the scale and scope of their
operation
so they'll ratchet up and then what
Higgs describes is that after that
crisis abates if you do see a decrease
in government activity but it never
quite goes back to the level that it was
before yeah and so I'm sure that if
people who know a lot more
about various specific pieces of
legislation better than I do would be
able to find examples where something
was put in and then subsequently taken
out but I think by and large the pattern
is confer the power might decrease a
little bit later on but still there's
not going to there's not that
contraction back to where we were yeah
so for the libertarians watching this
that want us to never have interventions
and be total pacifists and not do
anything here and take all our soldiers
and bases and bring all of that stuff
away the the economic repercussions of
something like that would would be
pretty severe right even even if the
morals behind what they wanted to do
were we're okay talking about like
closing bases in terms of a good
monetary issue yeah but if we really
were just for all the people that not
just libertarians but for plenty of
people that go why do we have bases in
Japan and why in a why are we protecting
them or why we bases in Germany still
this is in 1945 and all this other stuff
there's a lot of economic impact that
that would have beyond just the idea of
it would be nice not to have our troops
and people all over the world I mean we
could say undeniably like anything would
have an economic impact the question is
compared to what and that is the
question that is a lot harder to answer
because oftentimes when I'm talking to
people about foreign intervention and
they will ask the very loaded questions
so things like well wouldn't you want to
do this thing and prevent this terrible
atrocity that happened right I love
using loaded questions in a moment
excellent and those kinds of things it's
hard because you don't have a
counterfactual you can't say what would
have happened absent all of these
interventions so if instead of having
the military budget that we do now
instead of having all these military
bases had that funding been used for
something else
what would the economy look like yeah I
can't answer those questions and other
people can't either which is always nice
when you're put on the spot
I don't know but no one else knows
either right why is it that the
government always has more money for
bombs but then doesn't have money to do
other things that you might want them to
do is that just a function of this whole
thing is incentive for
you see the people are incentivized to
put their eggs in some baskets more than
others
and when it comes to foreign
intervention again whether we're talking
about things that appear to be
benevolent so whether it's intervention
for humanitarian purposes or whether it
is you know an offensive aggressive
intervention you have a lot of people
who have a vested interest in engaging
in those activities yeah as an economist
when when Trump was running and he was
saying things like you know we're going
to charge Japan to defend them and we're
going to do or maybe we're going to get
out of NATO now we're saying hey do all
the stuff that sort of had this populist
feel to it we're not going to spend so
much money overseas and all that did
that stuff resonate with you as like
sensible economic policy I tend to
prefer less intervention to more
intervention all of the trade policies
are a lot of trade policies so things
about you know will make Mexico pay for
the wall or things like that
I think that a lot of that reflects just
a poor understanding of of economics
yeah so who's in charge of his economic
policy do you know that the people know
really like everyone it seems to be that
it's always just coming off the top of
his head it's a good question although -
maybe this is the right way to say it to
his credit I don't know really with a
lot of presidents we're calling their
economic policy so again that is not
exclusive president Trump is that a
strange thing about Trump though in
general that it's like we don't really
know what the doctrine of Trump is like
even partly economically it's sort of
isolationist and then also he wants more
government involvement foreign policy at
all sort of seems the same so it makes
it tough to kind of figure out what's
going on we need a little bit but
politicians in general if you look at
the literature on public choice
economics there's a lot that discusses
why politicians say the things that they
do and there's a really good book
Holcombe I think came out with him just
last year it's a brief introduction to
public choice it's a relatively short
book but is very very good and he talked
about
if you listen to politicians they'll say
things over and over again that sound
really good but there's not actually a
lot of substance there good so you'll
see things like you know make America
great again or you know hope and change
all of these things sound really good
wonderful but then when you press
well what would these actual policies
look like there's not enough there's not
really any kind of firm backing there
it's just we're going to talk about
things very generally yeah and so that
also just the media's fall to like they
just love sound bites like that and if
there was a guy I mean that's what I
think now it's like if there was ever a
year coming up 2020 where we could have
someone that actually really wanted to
talk about issues and let's really talk
about the economy and let's really talk
about far about seeing all the things it
could be this coming election on both
sides and it's like that person would
get no coverage you know like if you was
just a guy who is like these are the
real issues forget the slogans
let's just talk it out there's
interesting things to be said about
media I know that there are a lot of
people who have researched how media has
evolved and changed over the years and
certainly it has from the time where if
you wanted news you had to go out in the
morning and grab your newspaper sit down
to now where I'm scrolling through
Twitter seeing a 104 years are the
latter um and so I think that's
definitely changed there's also some
interesting things to look at about
interaction between government in the
media so one project that I'm working on
now is examining how government
influences media particularly after 9/11
so looking at things like selling the
Iraq war or the Department of Defense
paying the NFL to do things which look
patriotic things like that so there's a
lot of interesting room for talking
about that I think yeah how much is the
government affecting our media directly
I think quite a bit this uh trying to
remember the exact number at this point
but I think it's the US government is
maybe the second largest PR firm so
they're spending a lot
both to craft its image domestically as
well as abroad yeah the abroad thing
people tend to I think these may be
maybe more aware of but domestically
there's a lot going on as well is there
any direct evidence of that like like
the real direct evidence between
government and media like sometimes I'll
see just out of nowhere suddenly like a
lot of stories will be written about one
specific thing at once through all the
mainstream you know or just even the way
the fake news meme you know no one had
heard of fake news then the day after
the election because the election didn't
go the way the mainstream media wanted
then then we all started talking about
fake news at the same time and then you
see political putting out the same story
that Daily Beast is putting out and all
that like is there a way to directly
link some of this back to what the
government's putting out in some cases
yes so one of the things that I was
reading actually on the plane to come
here
is looking at that sales pitch that the
Bush administration gave to the public
for the Iraq war and there was a point
where there was what they were referring
to as a feedback loop so you had people
like Vice President Cheney who were
saying well this is evidence about you
know Saddam Hussein and weapons of mass
destruction is coming that's not for me
that's coming from the New York Times
right however it was coming from the
Bush administration and so you do see
also in that same time period people who
were getting daily briefing from
administration officials on you know
what what was supposedly going on but
they were being pitched into networks as
being independent experts when really
their talking points had been given to
them by officials from the Bush
administration so there is definitely
places where you can draw those lines
very clearly yeah so the crumbling of
the mainstream media we can consider
that a good thing okay uh I don't know
all right so quickly let's boomerang
back to foreign policy and then we're
going to move on to tying out I say
boomerang and you know why because you
talk about the boomerang theory
can you explain what this is yes so my
co-author Chris Coyne and I we wrote a
paper titled perfecting tyranny
successful for free at the independent
Institute website what kind of
economist puts out a paper for free well
we did not elect to put it out for free
but I am totally excited that
independent is about putting out
knowledge to make it readily accessible
there and so we wrote this paper and
we're currently working on a book
Thunder contract no one's coming out
yeah still working on a title at this
point I saw they're bouncing around
between we are but we're trying to work
with the editors to figure out what
title would be best but the theory is
looking at the relationship between
foreign intervention and domestic policy
consequences because one thing with
foreign intervention is that people tend
to try to put foreign policy and
domestic policy into two completely
different spheres so foreign policy is
just that it's over there no
consequences
domestically whatsoever what we argue
though is that you really can't make
that distinction and in fact foreign
intervention can and does have a very
real impact domestically and for those
people who are concerned with issues of
scale and scope of government for people
who are issued are interested in issues
of civil liberties for an intervention
is something we really need to be paying
attention to so what we call our
framework is the boomerang effect so
explaining how it is that foreign
intervention serves as kind of a testing
ground for new types of social control
techniques and how those techniques
ultimately wind up back in the u.s. yeah
so can you give me an example is there
like an example from the Iraq war that
maybe we would play out for us so there
are a few things that we can talk about
the war on terror more broadly speaking
is a pretty good example of how some of
these policies have wound up being used
in the u.s. in the book we talk about a
few different examples so surveillance
is one of them we talk about domestic
police militarization and that's
connection to foreign intervention talk
about the use of drones domestically in
the United States and that foreign
connection so there are a lot of
different examples one thing that has
been interesting
and challenging about this work at the
same time is looking at examples and
getting all of the historical knowledge
that's necessary because one thing about
this type of research is that since you
are doing case studies you have to have
a lot of historical background so in the
cases like that like something like
drones and something like surveillance
basically the argument is that we sort
of test this stuff out across the world
and then we sort of bring it home and
use it against ourselves here like is
that test run is that just the
government's way of we start hearing
these words and it's about protection or
something and that's slowly we then just
acquiesce to it happening right here yes
I mean it's not necessarily one of those
we are doing this explicitly abroad to
try to do it at home right but one thing
that we can see in the u.s. is that for
if you look at a spectrum of functioning
governments whether you like it or not
US government relatively well
constrained relatively well functioning
compared to what else is out there
however if you take the US and other
governments too for that matter outside
of their own geographic boundaries their
constraints are much weaker or
altogether absent so there are lots of
US interventions for example of
including things like the 2003 invasion
of Iraq which are done without approval
of the UN and yet there are no sanctions
for that we talk about other reasons why
maybe those constraints aren't there so
you go out you are facing you being
government facing weaker or absent
constraints and so you can maybe try
things and do things that would not fly
domestically but that doesn't mean that
those things don't wind up showing up
back at home so we identify how it is
that those things come back so one way
is through what we call human capital so
just the skills that people possess so
in order to be successful in a foreign
intervention whatever your role is you
have to either possess or develop
particular skills and characteristics
when you finish with that foreign
intervention the individuals who are
involved they don't suddenly forget that
knowledge right they bring it back with
them this relates to the like
administrative dynamic of the
organizations in which these individuals
operate so whether that's a public
enterprise or a private enterprise they
may be well known for a particular skill
or it may just be the attitudes that
have been cultivated as a result of
these foreign interventions that they
then bring back with them and implement
into these organizations and physical
capital so the kinds of technologies
that are developed drones the prime
example drones are developed for use
abroad been used for a really long time
but extensively throughout the war on
terror people come back from these
interventions they see the potential use
for this technology that they have
become very accustomed to and then push
to have them used domestically right
some of that stuff I suppose at least on
the technological side can be used for
good right like Amazon using drones now
if it's going to get you your stuff
quicker and they got some of the
technological know-how through a
military thing that could be seen as
positive now having drones flying over a
spying on us all day this could be about
of course it's not to suggest that
anything that comes out before an
intervention is necessarily bad so I
think drones is a fantastic example
because there are certainly instances
where drones have very positive uses I
am really excited for the day that I can
get food delivered my throat yeah so
many I I will greatly look forward to
that day yeah drones have been used for
search and rescue they are used
extensively in agriculture and those are
all things that I think most people
would agree are great most people
probably wouldn't have too much of a
problem about those or with those but
once you start getting into those issues
of surveillance weaponized drones so you
have police departments who are
equipping drones with at this point
think mostly less lethal
weapons you start getting into those
kinds of areas and obviously you have
people who look at that and whoa whoa
right what's happening here and it also
goes to what you said earlier about sort
of the creep of all this because you
just said the phrase less lethal weapon
but it's almost like well now you've
just paved the road for eventually they
will have the lethal weapons on them
there are some states that are trying to
prevent that from happening
other states not so much and drones are
an interesting area of study because
they're not a new technology but the
rate at which they are being used is
substantially greater than at any point
before and so you are now seeing the
explosion of the use of this technology
yeah and so the question again comes to
those how do you get the uses that you
want out of those but avoid those things
that maybe we we don't want right and
all of these unintended consequences
when I live just across the hill in West
Hollywood there was a guy that was
flying a drone around the neighborhood
constantly so not only do you hear it
and you can see it obviously but I had a
little outdoor patio and it was like I
didn't know there's this guy have a
camera on this thing and it's staring at
me now that's not the government as it
well for all I know it was the
government but I'm assuming it was
somebody in there in the local area but
it's like you just start giving away
your privacy you don't even realize
what's happening and next thing you know
you've got a drone and they've got it
done and everyone's looking at everybody
and then who can hack into all this
stuff and write a myth there was a an
individual in my neighborhood who has a
drone and he likes flying it and at one
point there had been a couple of kids
he'd been breaking into cars in the
neighborhood and so he offered to fly
his drone around and sure enough within
you know just a few days of this being
offered you have people in the
neighborhood who are saying I don't want
that thing flying over my house because
they're genuinely concerned for their
their privacy right and so you get into
a lot of really interesting legal issues
issues of privacy social issues I think
with drones and so it'll be really
interesting
to see how this continues to unfold yeah
let's circle back to the surveillance
stuff related to the state though
because I haven't done a tremendous
amount on it in just in the last two
years or so because I feel like we don't
really talk about it that much anymore
like there was a point maybe four years
ago when all the NSA stuff first got
released and that ridiculous testimony
the James clapper gave in front of the
Senate House committee and just an all
and Rand Paul's filibuster and all that
stuff where it was like there was a
moment where it felt cool to be like
against the surveillance state then I
think that kind of disappeared very
quickly and it seems like we don't talk
about it anymore do you think that's
fair to say I think that there are
people who are still talking about it I
do think though that there is a definite
Evan flow to when people are talking
about it and not talking about it when
the Snowden leaks came out you had a lot
of people who are talking about it
before that Thomas Drake you had a lot
of people who are talking about it now
maybe not so much and people
surveillance is a hot-button issue even
for people who tend to be inclined
toward a smaller government or more
limited government when people talk
about surveillance they will usually say
things like well but it's making us
safer or I know my dad going through the
airport for example like well you know
as long as you know I don't have
anything to hide therefore yeah I don't
know that that's that's the worst I know
so the worst I try
have you made any headway there that's
the worst one to use uh you know maybe
but there are times to just you know if
you think you pick your battles with
parents a little much you turned into a
major psychotherapy and situation but
what happened there that we don't it
seems like just at least generally
speaking we now have just accepted that
there's a certain amount going on
between phone calls and Internet and
back doors on websites and all of this
other stuff like we just kind of all
accepted it is that just a function of
living in a Western democracy where
we've got it pretty decent and you
you can't fight everything all day I
like that's partly what I think it is I
think a lot of it comes back to that
fear issue that we we talked about
earlier is that people are genuinely
pretty bad at assessing risk and that's
not to say that people aren't smart just
that people tend to not do a very good
job of knowing how much of the threat
that something is and I think that
people get complacent so now the TSA
example again you go back before the
year 2000 and that seemed absolutely
preposterous now people just kind of
take it as a as a given and doesn't so
much of it seem like theatre to you like
whenever I go through I travel a lot and
it's like when I go through all this so
much of it seems like sort of nonsense
like they made me throw away my my hair
gel that it was like I just knew gel
like obviously I was like you guys want
to smell it like put it in my hair right
now like I'm not trying to build a bomb
here I only had a carry-on a little
backpack with me like you can look at
everything else I can't build like that
it just seems like well this is why we
do this and this is why we do this and
they were throwing away all this like
perfectly good stuff and fresh bottles
of water all those other stuff can't be
economically sensible either there's a
lot of discussion about the TSA a
security theater pretty much any report
that you read about the TSA indicates
that they are not effective at all
producing any kind of terrorist threat
and are spending a ton of money on an
annual basis it comes back to that
bureaucracy point because then when you
have the TSA who is giving itself an
exam and it fails 95 percent of the time
it is not a time for reflection of well
is this really doing the job that we
want it to do instead is that we need
more beer available any more money we
need better technology and rayna less
Magloire so they do these things right
they do these tests where they have
people try to get stuff through and fail
it fails something like 95% of anomic
right so people are getting it with
knives and all sorts of other crazy
things right and then the answer is not
how do we fix this the answers always we
got to throw more money because it goes
back to the earlier things right so this
responses because when you when you're
confronted with failure or less than
stellar performance as a bureaucratic
agency you've got a couple of different
choices you can decide well that didn't
work we should just ban this and try
something else or you can say this was
really not our fault it was because we
didn't have the funding that we need it
didn't have the technology that we
really needed and so there's always that
fallback of it's not failure on our part
its failure because we didn't have the
resources that we needed yeah and
there's the same political problem that
you mentioned earlier about closing down
you know a tank manufacturing place that
we don't need it's that if any
politician was like you know what we're
going to cut the TSA by 20 percent and
try the string line or whatever and then
there was a terror attack well that guy
is going to be voted out of office
immediately if not impeached or some
other situation so we've really created
this mod disliked self-sustaining
monster here right how do we beat this
most give me some answers a
million-dollar question I challenge this
my students with this all the time but
if they can figure out things like a
alternative drug policy that is
politically viable a war on terror
policy that is politically viable or
social security that's the other if they
can figure out a workable solution will
you go and collect your billion dollar
check yeah retire and let me know yeah
it's these issues are really complicated
and one thing that I know I find a
really humbling is that I don't have the
answers and I don't think anybody really
does so when you look at issues like
surveillance when you look at things
like police militarization when you look
at things like the war on drugs you are
confronting a potentially infinite
number of vested interest I think at a
bare minimum changing any one of those
things requires a massive shift in
public opinion which oftentimes I think
it's a pretty heroic assumption in and
of itself but even if you do have that
major shift in public opinion then you
have to figure out well how do you
entangle these interest that you've
spent in often times with decades
cultivating these relationships between
government and private industry how do
you go about divorcing those and I don't
have a clear answer I've had a lot of
academics in here I don't know that I've
had anyone say that they don't have a
clear answer on something that's
actually quite refreshing well thank you
it's true though I get really nervous
when I hear a economist saying that they
have a very particular policy
prescription of this will fix whatever
the problem and because one thing that
economics teaches us is that every
policy has costs and has benefits and so
no policy that you implement is going to
be perfect at the end of the day the
question that we want to ask is how good
of a job do the policies that we are
implementing do of achieving the
particular goals that were interested in
working toward mmm anyone check this
stuff does anyone go back and go let's
you know like when when they were just
trying to get this other health care the
Trump health care thing or the Paul Ryan
health care day whatever it is passed
and it was like well the CBO says it'll
cost X amount and it's like well they
had projections when Obamacare was
coming across like does anyone look back
and go because I just don't trust any of
the numbers you know like you're giving
me a number before this thing is kicked
in like we crunched some numbers but as
you're saying there's all these
unintended consequences all these other
things that happen does anyone ever go
back and go you know let's look at all
the projections that the government made
all these nonpartisan groups and all
this stuff for the last twenty years and
did anyone get any of these projections
right I feel like they probably are
never right I mean any time we're doing
forecasting you have to make certain
assumptions sometimes the assumptions
that you make wind up being pretty good
and other times they are totally off the
mark no I think it's something that you
know economists have predicted twice as
many recessions or something as there
have actually been but certainly if you
go back and you look at what people have
said with regard to policy
you'll find that some piece
all have maybe been accurate some people
a lot of people have have not do we
learn from a mistake right is awesome I
think that that's a taller order and
again I think it comes back to the very
symbol what incentives do you face even
though people might be aware that a
policy hasn't really been effective does
that really change the motivation that
they have we're continuing the policy
and in a lot of cases the answer to that
question is no yeah so you've done a lot
of videos with learn Liberty about some
of the stuff we've talked about and
we'll link to some stuff below so people
can check that also one of the other
things you talk about a lot is police
militarization and how we've watched
that really expand I think it's directly
directly related to everything going on
with the surveillance state how much has
this expanded you know we see now when
there's riots and whatever we see things
that look like tanks on our streets we
see police officers that look like
soldiers I don't think we saw that not
too long ago you didn't so
the trend of police militarization is
something that people really talk about
starting to happen in the 1960s I think
there were some trends prior to that I
didn't really take off like it did until
you hit really Vietnam and then war on
drugs and that actually is one of the
things that we talked about in looking
at and linking up foreign policy to
domestic domestic consequences so police
military hi yeah no so in this case like
we had the Vietnam War we then get
protests against it and then the state
kind of uses that as an excuse to become
more militarized swat teams are probably
one of the best examples SWAT teams are
now something that pretty much any
moderately sized Police Department has
so if you have a town of 50,000 or more
people
chances are you have got a SWAT team so
special weapons and tactics teams also
refer to as police paramilitary units or
PP use so the fact about the word
military America is fairly uh yeah
fairly pointed but where did those come
from we actually know we
actly where they came from you have two
people who are generally considered
responsible for SWAT teams Daryl gates
and John Nelson
so John Nelson is a was a former Marine
Vietnam veteran he was part of the elite
Force Recon unit so this unit was tasked
with going deep behind enemy lines and
despite having the name reconnaissance
in the title they were actually a very
effective killing force they engaged the
enemy I think with something 90% of the
time which was incredibly high and he
came back joined the LAPD and you have
the Watts Riots and looking at these
race riots he goes to his boss so
inspector Daryl gates who the World War
two veteran and says hey I have an idea
of how we might be able to better
control crowds and he suggests modeling
a unit after these recon units that he's
been a part of in Vietnam and so gates
likes this idea runs with it
and what was originally supposed to be
called the special weapons and attack
team but it was thought of tactics
politically unpalatable
SWAT team was born it's modeled after
that particular unit according to the
LAPD history every member of the
original SWAT unit had prior military
training they were interested in and if
you read gates biography he talks about
watching what was happening in Vietnam
getting training from the military and
so you start to see these kinds of very
intimate connections that are happening
between police and military and they're
interested in using not only those
mentalities that they've cultivated
abroad but they're also interested in
using those technologies that they've
developed how do we well if you had your
druthers but these things just not exist
at all like policing would just be
purely the way it was before all this
so policing historically in the United
States has been distinct from the
military so if you look at the
institution if you look at laws that
came after that probably the big one
that people point to was enacted right
after the Civil War called the Posse
Comitatus Act and I don't even know that
one so that was Posse Comitatus
literally translates to force of the
people and so the purpose of this law
was to separate police from the military
the military could not be used as a
civilian police force pretty much as
soon as the ink is dry this thing is
getting violated it's getting suspended
in think world war one world war two
then there are series of court cases in
the 1970s that pretty much take any kind
of sticking power but this thing had to
begin with completely out of it and so
you see this big blurring of these lines
in addition to things like SWAT teams
which comes within this time period the
war on drugs and the voluntary
particularly important because you see
that continued interconnectivity between
domestic law enforcement agencies and
what the federal government is doing so
now you have police departments who
instead of having their job which has
historically been to be peacekeepers
right uphold domestic law protecting the
rights of citizens both individuals who
are the perpetrators of crime and the
victims of crime instead of serving that
function they are now on quote-unquote
the frontlines of to perpetual Wars the
war on drugs and the war on terror which
are different from other conflicts that
we've seen before because you think
about Vietnam or one of the world wars
the enemy is very clearly defined and
external to the United States but with
the war on drugs you not only have
things like South American cartels that
you have people who are domestically
manufacturing selling and consuming
drugs who are enemies of this war yeah
there's been a big emphasis on homegrown
terrorism and so now your Police
Department's are tasked with another job
that is not part of their job
description and so it's been building in
a combination of all of these things I
think it's really contributed to
to this police militarization which now
I think a lot of people are more aware
of yeah it seems like we're slowly
getting accepting of it because if you
look at you could look at you know
something like Ferguson and then you
could look at something like what's
happened at Berkeley and in both cases
you see a big sort of state response but
I've talked to people who said that the
police weren't doing anything you know
like at Berkeley that the police were
just sort of letting an tyfa run off run
across and be violent do all this stuff
and then other people are going to have
to step in so we're in a strange place
with policing in general see lately I
think that police and I've made this
argument to people when talking about
policing and in talking about the
military to that I think a lot of times
the job that's been pushed on members of
law enforcement and members of the
military is particularly unfair one
thing we talk about
in economics is ideas comparative
advantage you do what it is that you're
particularly good at soldiers are not
trained in you know to be humanitarians
like that is not their their job
description police officers their job
description is to speak and peacekeepers
but it is a precarious position and
often times people will say things like
well but if you're the people that
they're fighting have you know tanks and
ak-47s like don't you want them to have
a superior firepower which my response
is always yeah maybe but if you look at
what people are actually fighting
police officers with or the probability
of being shot and killed if you're a
police officer can it that risk
assessment thing that people aren't
particularly good at right I think
police have been good put put in a
position that they weren't intended to
be in and often times when we see police
are being used like SWAT teams again
provide a really good example SWAT teams
are used in a lot of times in cases
where people would look at that and say
there's really a hard case to saying
that
appropriate like you have SWAT teams who
are being used when people are
threatening suicide for example I have a
hard time swearing in my brain people
going out in full Kevlar in a Bearcat
so they forward mine resistant vehicle
for someone who's threatening to you
know shoot themselves in their house
part of that is I think part of the
stipulations on the equipment that a lot
of police forces are getting so this
came along with that war on drugs and
war on terror people who are familiar
may be familiar with a Department of
Defense program that allows for the
transfer of excess military equipment to
law enforcement part of that include
they use it or lose it provision so if
you don't use the equipment as a police
department within a year you're supposed
to return it right harwitum defense
which goes back to what we said earlier
they never want to return it I always
want to spend more so now you literally
have the SWAT team with this all this
crazy stuff going out to to stop a guy
that maybe is jumping off the bridge
right and it creates a really strong
incentive to use these items even in
cases where they aren't appropriate
pretty I guess infamous example would be
the word Keene New Hampshire the town of
about 20,000 people haven't had a murder
in something like two decades and yet
their Police Department got a Bearcat so
a mine resistant vehicle yeah um it's a
little higher it's all over New
Hampshire right right very much
everywhere and so there are lots of
cases where you see things and this is
this is not to say that you know police
having the equipment that they need is
not something that's that's necessary
yeah but I think that we should be
turning a very critical eye to what it
is that has happened in u.s. Police
Department's because I think it's a it's
been a growing issue for a long time but
when you start to have things like
Ferguson really put a spotlight on it in
a way that I was frankly surprised
because prior to that the thing that
people forget about is Watertown
Massachusetts so after the bombing of
the Boston Marathon
you have you know police who are
removing people from their homes to
search for the suspected bombers with no
kind of pretense for thinking that they
were in a person's house issuing curfews
and things like that and that to me was
a much stronger display of the kinds of
things that I'm talking about but
Ferguson is what what gets the play
yeah so the through line through
everything we've talked about for an
hour has been just sort of that this
thing just kind of grows it kind of
grows for economic reasons and for
political reasons and everything else so
to kind of wrap this all up if if
someone's watching this and goes why I
don't like that I don't like this idea
that this thing's growing all the time
and taking more money and not doing
things that are economically sound or
socially sound and I don't want more
militarized police on the streets on all
that what would you say are some of the
ways that we can start influencing our
politicians and other people to real
some of this stuff back in I think one
thing that people can do is to really
educate themselves about things like the
terror threat so knowing that you're
more likely to be killed by a gun
wielding toddler yeah thank you are you
killing by here freak out every time I
see you talk deal Gerry they're
dangerous um knowing that being aware
that what is happening today Canon does
have a very real impact on what may
happen tomorrow and that's not intended
to be alarmist or very you know tinfoil
hat like yummy super careful because
they're going to try to use this for
something right um but to look at and be
aware of these types of issues to
understand how it is that we've gotten
to this point because there is one thing
and that we say this toward I think in
the conclusion of our book it's just
because we see these things doesn't
necessarily mean that it's a permanent
state of affairs and one thing that can
be a very effective control on
inappropriate expansions in the
Gaylen scope of government is the
ideology of the citizenry and so there
have been cases historically where you
look and people just they're not willing
to swallow certain things yeah when
people when their elected officials
attempt them and so if people make their
voice heard if they develop and they
articulate those preferences that this
is not something that is acceptable I
think that there's a real power there so
be smart be engaged be aware I think
those are all the things I've been I've
been trying to do around here I've
thoroughly enjoyed this and for more on
Abby and her work you can check out
Abigail our Hall
[Music]
you
[Music]